yes triple-a says that nearly 50 million
Americans will travel this fourth of
July weekend they're going to be
spending more on their vacations this
summer than they did a year ago
according to travel and hospitality
marketing firm MMG why global well
joining us now with a look at the
biggest trends in travel is the CEO of
the company Clayton read his company
just released its 25th annual portrait
of an American traveler and claimed I
was looking through some of the
highlights of this report Millennials
interestingly enough as we were
mentioning earlier in the show they're
doing more staycations you know I think
Millennials are actually miscast in the
media quite a bit i believe i think a
lot of people consider millennials only
that 18 to 25 year old who who is very
adventurous and wants to go to exotic
places well the fact is we define
millennials is 18 to 35 year olds when
it comes to travel okay and in fact the
largest spenders in millennial travel
are Millennials with kids and families
so yes we see a lot of move for
Millennials to travel shorter distances
and more times which is allows for their
budget and I still want to take exotic
trips too but there's a lot of interest
in traveling in their own backyard right
so isn't more than half of them looking
at least looking to stay around their
arable times during the year the other
thing that's interesting about
Millennials for those that take longer
trips ones that want to take more exotic
trips they're actually using travel
agents at a higher incidence than in any
other cohort demographic yeah because we
think they're bus experienced travelers
and they want some guidance and it's
it's come out to travel websites that's
right probably again I still use a lot
of travel websites to write just in
terms of index they're using travel
agents bricks-and-mortar traditional
travel agents more than other age groups
which is counterintuitive when you think
about how a moment al is define so how
come you did there is a there is kind of
a gray area and when defining
Millennials right so why do you define
in a broader eight you know age group
here right so another misperception
millenniums were actually the largest
demographic in the United States today
84 million Millennials within the United
States contrast that with boomers were
there are only 78 million so and that is
18 to 35 year olds Millennials as
defined and things that you don't expect
for example they want to cruise at
very high level you typically think of
cruises and travels the province of
older people right and it is 65 and
older and it is a lot of boomers and
matures take cruises but actually and
it's an all-time high for us in our
25-year study the intent to cruise at is
an all-time high forty-eight percent of
americans say they want to take a cruise
and 51 percent of millennials say they
want to take a cruise which again is
counterintuitive that is also the trap
you know speaking about you know the
travel websites and it reminds me of
like the online shared served share
travel services right like so air B&B
and you and others I mean are you seeing
any impact on those kinds of companies
from the change in fact huge impact
eighteen percent of us travelers have
used a shared economy service and travel
at some point in the last 12 months that
could be an accommodation like an Airbnb
or a home away it could be uber for
example and of those though Millennials
are the largest segment of roughly
eighty percent of those eighteen percent
are Millennials but seventy-four percent
are Gen Xers and seventy two percent
boomers who are using shared services to
your point and as it relates to some of
the major lodging companies for example
for every one percent of growth at
Airbnb or home away in a home
accommodation yeah the lodging industry
to traditional lodging industry is
losing about a quarter percent of
revenue and it is a serious implicate it
has threesome plication for the life
community and I notice that on the
survey right tripadvisor is what tops
across the board or is it just among
certain segments well you just reported
about Delta pulling out of tripadvisor
on airline side but tripadvisor is
absolutely the most important influencer
of lodging decisions in the United
States and one of the things that came
out of our study is traditional online
travel agencies like Expedia priceline
Travelocity are actually losing traction
with the US traveler ha and TripAdvisor
and other meta search engines like kayak
like trivago are picking up some of that
volume interesting all right well good
for a tripadvisor I guess right I do use
it to when I travel Clayton thank you so
much anyway of MMG white global on the
american traveler